hello and welcome to this video playing
caste dress yeah i'm not good with that
so i have no no knowledge of the spanish
language cafe con leche
i can do stuff like that okay try to
slav
i have not studied the chivanenko slaw
form
forever basically recently alex kolovich
released the repertoire on the
chebanenko on chesable
so it's good i already had a brief look
at his suggestions
okay i remember this kind of
this kind of variations back when i
played the chebanenko regularly
sloth so slav is a very reliable opening
can only recommend that
all the two wide range of players it's
kind of
a good mixture of being solid and still
having some interesting ideas
okay queen here
not sure about my play the last couple
of moves if i did good damn
i did good there questionable english
probably
um if i take 97 i'm attacking two pawns
that is nice
queen d4 probably
yeah i'm still doing that i think there
are the alternatives look to
look too bleak so takes e5
i saw this line and felt that this
should be
reasonable
not sure that this helped him
okay um
i wonder what what white's ideas is e4
move
if i have bishop e6 okay
i wonder
about possible active ideas maybe d4 is
one
have to be timed correctly though like
here this is an idea
to push that pawn i'm only a little bit
worried about that
that diagonal okay so
step out of that
and try to
push deform i'm a little bit surprised
that he's going for that
i feel this just weakens him somewhat i
mean
i understand that he wants to make some
progress somehow and it just
just doesn't want to hang around but i
think that
i'm not unhappy here to
to have those pawns to attack
what is that like i did don't i get d3
now quickly maybe
d3 bishop takes rook rook on the seventh
looks kind of
dangerous
and does he want to go back
or am i overlooking something i don't
know
bishop takes i go rook d8
d8
rook d7 does bishop takes f6 and then he
has
this this idea
but i can take here right and introduce
this
check
into the position and potentially b4
which can be
highly irritating
rook d7 was playable like bishop f6 rook
d3 this
queen h6 is probably playable but
this looks fine right
b4 rook b3
don't see a good reply
queen d7 maybe
trying to pin it like that
look here there's b4
yeah that's a possible move
shoot no time spend too much time
trying to oops
trying to
exploit that pin
and now i'm getting really low on time
[Music]
i have this check also
i have to keep that in mind the check is
important
12 seconds crazy
i could have taken i think but
i don't really know what he is playing
now i'm i'm on that
uh check
let's mate here also right this is kind
of kind of a problem
so i won that game interesting one
let's have a look like right here out of
the opening
like knight e5 and he went with this
f3 and c5 i didn't want to play bishop
e7 that looked too passive to me
if the the sequence from the game works
then
i think this is preferable f6
takes
yeah the engine wants to play queen c3
rook takes and then b4
it's kind of similar to the game just
with the rook on f7
so if we look at this a little bit
rookie eight that that was already
intending deform
so king here and i was surprised i
didn't i don't think b5
is such a fantastic idea it just like
looks like weakening the whole thing
engine wants to play rook a3
yeah it's probably roughly equal
okay so here it took and pushed d4
and now white should probably not take
but rather move the queen
yeah what i was thinking is that if he
moves the queen
not sure like here that oops
something like that would happen and
this felt okay i have this
and the pieces are active so it should
work
and this is looking pretty pretty grim
took it r8 rook a3
so i played this reasonable i think
c takes rook c1
queen d7 is equal
this i thought he can take on f6 right
and i'm even
in trouble um
yeah i'm even in trouble so i have to do
this
queen d7 i know i don't have to do that
but it's better
yeah what i did not see at this point is
that idea
queen e7 possibly to e3 in some lines
okay queen d7 rook d1
queen e8 with the dual idea
again looking at this and this uh
queen c2 and now rook fd7 now
i didn't do that too badly like with no
time on the clock relatively low time on
the clock it was reasonably played
this and king g7 was just a pragmatic
decision
but i think i can take yeah i can take
because he only has one check here you
can check him but it's just it's just a
check
and white can never take
twice
because of that made
therefore i'm basically winning tempe
yeah he has to react due to the threats
yeah king g7 is
even losing due to rookie one oh my
goodness
i would have been a cold shower really
i didn't see rookie one at all that
tempo on my queen
i didn't see that i thought i can just
like conveniently
exploit the situation next move
with uh yeah mtp played queen f4 and
panicked
and then it's just lost him okay
didn't i shouldn't have given him that
chance but um
i it was an interesting game thanks for
watching